[Music]
elon musk causes a ruckus with fake
pocahontas
yeah the billionaire of space verbally
declawed the hapless indian fraud
senator elizabeth warren if that's her
real name
started this childish feud with the
world's richest man on monday when she
tweeted let's change the rigged tax code
so the person of the year will actually
pay taxes and stop freeloading off
everyone else
it's weird to me though that when rich
people forget that they're also rich
warren herself is a millionaire she
should know that right i never forget
i'm rich i pay someone five dollars an
hour to remind me several times a day
thanks cat check's late now
but elon was having none of it replying
stop projecting and linking to an old
fox news article calling her a fraud we
appreciate the shout out elon you're
welcome to do the show as soon as you
make a tesla big enough for tyrus to fit
in
but musk came back with an even bigger
burn tweeting you remind me of when i
was a kid and my friend's angry mom
would just randomly yell at everyone for
no reason
and please don't call the manager on me
senator karen
that is some
trump-level tweeting right there that
slam hurts more than the pain joe biden
feels simply getting out of bed
we go to senator karen for comment
oh wow if it isn't a lon mush i call you
a lon mush in honor of the cornmeal
recipe i contributed to the cherokee
chow cook book okay i'm about ready to
go tribal sovereignty on your ass okay
i am going to give a hundred and ten
percent of my point one nine percent
indigenous blood to make sure people
like you pay their fair share
okay and by fair share i mean fair share
of contributions to my next failed
presidential campaign
okay all right i'll see you
you know kat the art of a good tweet is
when somebody describes somebody so well
that
you can't actually never see unsee it
again and like when she musk described
her as his boyhood friend's mom who just
yells at people
that's almost like putting her on ice
i kind of disagree though
i don't think she's a karen
i think she's more of a
sharon ooh really it's something i just
made up but i'll explain it yeah it's
like karen will call the cops but a
sharon will like not call the cops and
talk about how she would never call the
cops all the time as a replacement for
the personality that she'll never have
like karen would be like kids keep it
down but sharon will show up
like hey kids want to hit my vape pen
they're like you're 70 we're 20. go home
sharon
like
she wants to be cool and edgy so bad but
she never will be that is that's a
sharon she's a sharon interesting
kennedy uh that's an interesting
analysis sharon is she not aware that
elon musk probably pays more taxes than
anybody on earth no absolutely
facts do not matter to the progressive
tax conversations very similar to the
cancel college debt conversation
they will employ things that no one fact
checks but they are completely
false and think of the number of people
that elon musk supports uh with spacex
and tesla and his hyperloop that he's
someday going to build and
someday we'll be able to fly through the
air and disintegrate and then reform oh
yes he's going to invent so much cool
stuff that if i were her i would be nice
to him yes but he also and and i think
she is kind of a camera because she
became the manager so she's like a super
karen so she she was appealing to power
but now she's so powerful that she wants
to squash everyone she has a beef with
and i like that he tweets things of
people like her and bernie sanders he
tweeted at bernie sanders you're still
alive yeah that was a good one
you know you get the feeling that musk
is one of us not and he's ability we get
the best people on our side madison he's
do it is true what kennedy is saying
he's when you compare him to a
politician he's doing more
for this world especially in space
exploration and batteries
than any politician or corporation so
it's kind of nice to see him just
flatten uh pretentious loudmouth yeah so
really four things on this when he when
he said bernie sanders four things
congressman i'll go really fast number
one he had a great podcast recently
talking about world war ii you should go
check it out hardcore history phenomenal
number two if anybody is selling one of
his flamethrowers from the boring
company i will buy it uh number three if
he ever gets really commercial orbital
flight where you can just fly up in
space it's one of my lifelong plans to
smoke a cigar and last thing number four
i think he should be our secretary of
transportation next oh yeah
phenomenal yeah
he certainly will not take paternity
leave judging by his history
he likes to have the kids but then he
moves on he has a lot of kids tyrus
speaking of don't go there i won't
what do you think about this feud uh
it's exactly what we talked about the
the progressive woke administration's
need for the 3 a.m tweet
so he is their new trump because now the
battle with him is going to try to
deflect what the horrible things is
going on in the administration talked
about how they're upset that president
trump was no longer on tw twitter to
fight with right so now
she's she was the first one and they
drew him in and although his his this is
phenomenal as a guy who likes to do mic
drop disses they're up there he's a
billionaire with a billionaire brain
it's phenomenal but unfortunately
he just to unfortunately took the bait
because now they're all going to come at
him now yes that will be the top story
now they're going to go in the
background now they're going to try to
even though he's a little like i don't
even need your federal funding for my
electric cars i don't need it they're
still going to go at him because now
they found somebody to distract yeah i
also don't they're going to thought that
she existed yeah but now we remember i
had to like really recall that i went
back i had to use that i saw him in the
hallway one time i was like holy who was
that yes
all right
will be next yeah
then the vp they're all gonna get in
line because they're going to get
attention yeah i hear he's back with
grimes too that's kind of heartbreaking
they're semi-separated
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else